Think about this, tech jobs, freelancing and remote work opportunities are booming,
but what if you don't have a laptop or stable internet?
What if you've never learned how to code or navigate digital platforms?
The divide is no longer just about who has technology,
it's about who gets to use it to create a better life.
The digital divide isn't just a developing world issue.
Even in rich countries, the gap is growing.
In the US, millions of rural communities lack reliable broadband.
In major cities, low-income neighborhoods often have fewer public Wi-Fi spots,
outdated computer labs and limited digital literacy programs.
And here's where it gets even more serious,
that digital divide isn't just about convenience, it's about survival.
During the pandemic, people with internet access could work remotely.
Those without it? Many lost their jobs.
Access to healthcare is also shifting online.
Telemedicine, online health portals and digital prescriptions are becoming the norm.
But what about those who can't afford internet or don't know how to use digital healthcare services?
They receive worse medical care simply because they lack access to a screen.
And think about democracy.
Political debates, news updates and even voting are increasingly digital.
When people lack digital access, they're not just disconnected from technology,
they're disconnected from decision-making.